نظام نور تم هو النظام الخاص بالملاحه
يحتوي على معلومات اساسيه للافراد
المعنيين بعمليات الطيران ويستخدم لغه
خاصه تجعل الاتصال اكثر فعاليه
يقدم النظام وتحديثا مباشرا للاوضاع
الطبيعيه وغير الطبيعيه للمجال الجوي
ويرسل تنبيهات للطيارين من مخاطر محتمله
طوال مسار الرحله
هو اختصار لتعبير تنبيهم مهمات الطيران اي
نوت ستورم الشمس باللغه الانجليزيه
واخرى قد تصلوا لاربعين دقيقه
انواع الطيران المدني والعسكريه على حد
الثواب وتخصص نسخه منه لاستخدام الطيارين
واخرى لاستخدام المطارات
يحتوي النظام نفسه على عده تقسيمات تبدا
من المناطق الجويه المحيطه بالمطارات
نفسها وتتفرع الى مؤشرات حول السلامه
الممرات الجويه وتغيير مجرى الهواء
بما ان النظام يعمل على تحذير الطيارين
والافراد المعنيين بالطيران من المخاطر
المحتمله طوال مسار الرحله فان تعطله يعني
انه لا يكون بمقدور التيار رصد الاخطار
التي قد تكون محيطه به وكذلك المطارات في
حركه الطيران القادم والمغادر